chess.com is about playing
at any moment there are thousands of
people from around the world playing on
chess.com so whether you're a total
beginner or a grand master you'll find a
game quickly with someone at your level
you can play at any pace from one minute
bullet to five-minute blitz to 60 minute
games or you can play more relaxed games
where you have several days to make your
move there are tournaments starting
every few minutes or you can play
against our customizable coaching
computer chess.com is for learning chess
isn't just about playing it's about
getting better
chess.com puts the best training tools
at your fingertips
sharpen your game with over 50 000
tactics puzzles improve your strategy
with training videos by top grand
masters get instant feedback after your
games with real-time computer analysis
regardless of where you're at now you
can take your game to the next level
chess.com is for sharing join the
community where you can discuss chess
ideas in the forums and follow the
latest chess news or join a club with
friends and play in a league against
other clubs you can find all this in
your browser at home and at work or on
the go with your phone or tablet
signing up is free and easy
so what are you waiting for
enjoy your game